lavigne un paysage contournable de la
région centre val de loire des
appellations connu dans le monde entier
pourtant aujourd'hui les vignerons ne
sont plus seulement ceux qui produisent
le vin ils sont aussi des hommes
d'affaires et doivent rivaliser
d'imagination pour attirer les visiteurs
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le monde de lune au
tourisme un business qui conjugue le
plaisir des papilles et la découverte
première étape de notre périple le
domaine de la famille coulis à chinon
depuis le 15e siècle
[Musique]
la vie c'est le lien à la fois de la
tradition de la famille et c'est aussi à
moi quelque chose de très conviviale
c'est aussi un moyen de partage donc
c'est vraiment tout ce qu on partage les
valeurs aussi con partager des valeurs
importantes de transmission puisqu'une
vinsa se transmet de génération en
génération c'est le travail des
générations précédentes qu'on va aussi
essayer de transmettre aux enfants
aujourd'hui le domaine est ancré dans le
21e siècle avec sa salle de dégustation
ultramoderne qui accueille des visiteurs
venus se creuser les méninges
les minimes elles vont être de tutti
c'est des énigmes chiffres et ça peut
être du décodage ça peut être des
charades des jeux de mots des jeux de
l'aide des actions à faire il ya de tout
direction le chai où notre famille va
tenter de relever le défi
voilà les skates game est un jeu
d'évasion composé d'énigmes que les
participants doivent résoudre en une
heure pour pouvoir sortir de la pièce on
a beaucoup de choses venez voir 24 24
car tu as trouvé donc là c'est peut-être
en rapport avec les tarifs imbattables
dans le code à 4 chiffres
ça c'est la découverte surtout qu'on ne
sait pas où on va on est à la retombée
du cuir et fumé pendant ce temps perché
sur une cuve michel cool y dirige les
opérations peine un peu sur le
déchiffrage comme beaucoup d'équipés
ceci est une épreuve dette il faut tout
déchiffrer et on a toujours tendance à
vouloir sauter une partie de l'énigme
ce qui fait qu'on cherche pas le bon
glee pas la bonne année et ils se sont
beaucoup posé de questions sur écrire en
fait il un tableau noir et l'excès dans
la pièce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé qui
n'ont pas vu pour l'instant je fais
reprendre savoir où ils en sont
[Musique]
crédit-cartes bassin kevin
né fin du temps imparti
notre petit groupe n'a pas résolu
l'énigme ya un chiffre partout j'avais
entendu l'existence de ces tesquet
bienne et c'était l'occasion de lier la
passion de mon beau-père l'oenologie
avec ma passion à moins qu'elle est ce
qu'elle game du coup c'est ce qui m'a
donné l'idée de lui offrir sa pour noël
c'est pour ça qu'on est ici aujourd'hui
enfin libérée nos joueurs ont droit à
une visite commentée du chef avant de
s'attabler pour une dégustation avec la
construction de cette salle dédiée au
tourisme
le domaine à multiplier par cinq le
nombre de visiteurs dont 2000 cette
année ont goûté aux joies de l'escape
game
à la grande surprise du patriarche
pierre coulis
est-ce que bien que j'ai mis longtemps
mais maintenant la tête pour le répéter
en plus bétonné sexe était complètement
farfelu que je me voyais pas renfermé
payer pour être enfermés pendant une
heure et trouver l'énigme
ça me dépasse a créé la surprise est
finalement venue beaucoup de générations
différentes autour du jeune qui est un
peu plus pour le jeu et puis les autres
qui sont intéressés par le sujet donc du
coup on met tout le monde dans la même
salle et renfermé il arrive à en sortir
moi je suis fils d'immigré et féret que
pendant un moment
être français qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et donc découvrir un peu le vin un peu
la charcuterie française
tout ça ça permet de passer de
s'intégrer mais de s'approprier un peu
le patrimoine français
depuis le développement de
l'oenotourisme
les ventes à la bouteille ont augmenté
et le travail du vigneron a évolué et a
fallu apprendre des nouveaux métiers les
métiers du tourisme
parce que ça suffit page que vous et
mettre une pancarte faux pas et
d'attendre que le client il faut faire
venir le client fois les aussi
communiquer les des agences de voyages
avec des tour opérateurs avec des gens
qui vont ramener le public et un autre
public qui vont pas être seulement le
public que l'on rencontre au bonnaroo
quoi c'est aussi notre démarche aller
vers les gens nous suivons le cher pour
arriver à bourg et au domaine des
tabourets léché anne josso pionnière de
l'oenotourisme au sein de l'appellation
touraine chenonceaux une fille de
viticulteurs qui a dû faire sa place
je
on a retrouvé en recherchant qui peut
que ce que les premières vignes dans ma
famille avait été géré en 1844 donc pour
moi ça me paraissait indispensable de
pouvoir reprendre et continuer cette
histoire de famille et pour moi les
vignes c'est vraiment voilà l'ancrage
dans la terre et est d'ailleurs pour
être pour être vignerons et vigneronnes
il faut vraiment avoir s'agirait dans
les tripes
parce que c'est quand même pas un métier
facile et donc faut vraiment avoir envie
le domaine des tabourets elle est
adossée aux coteaux du cher une
particularité qui fait de la caf dan un
endroit unique en france
attention la tête attention à la tête
pas attention à la tête ça va peser sur
mon voyage en route
on y va c'est un labyrinthe
troglodytique de près de 30 kilomètres
que vont découvrir une cinquantaine de
touristes en compagnie de stéphane le
beau frère d'âme
vous allez voir dans une dizaine de
minutes vous allez voir un curieux
sentiment celui d'être complètement
perdu parce que ça part dans tous les
sens si on n'a pas l'habitude d'être
dans les milieux souterrains il faut 10
mai pour ce père taille de plus pas une
de moins
c'est un sanctuaire
pour la prise de mousse des fines bulles
de touraine vous êtes sur un domaine
viticole et donc tous les vins du
domaine sont stockés entre 300 m et 6
cents mètres d'ici on descend en chariot
élévateur pour stocker les palettes
demain mais avant tout cet endroit
exceptionnel et la plus grande carrière
d'extraction de la pierre de tuffeau qui
a servi à construire les châteaux de la
loire
la richesse du patrimoine bâti de la
région centre val de loire
elle est entièrement construit en
tuffeau il a bien fallu alimenter ce
territoire on va dire de construction
c'est le cheikh qui épouse annie de
démarcation ou ici vous êtes en
allemagne physiquement ils sont
concrètement de l'autre côté du cher
vous êtes en france les résistances les
dessins les évidemment tout cela c'est
logique quand on nous l'expliquent mais
c'est intéressant
[Musique]
c
qui dit réseau souterrain des réseaux
hydrauliques alors voilà la marmite à
popol ça fait six mille cinq cents litre
c'est parfaitement intarissable ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas que ce qu'on cueille au
moment l'année même sur le sur le cep
en fait c'est ça c'est une histoire de
plusieurs siècles est en fait le
patrimoine
je dirais bâtiments comme le patrimoine
d'élevage comme le vin ou en fait tout
est lié et secondes
ma foi de de la nature à une noblesse
peut-être d'autres villes
le citadin oublié après une heure de
visite
nos touristes retrouve anne pour une
dégustation dans une partie des
troglodytes aménagé en barre la
particularité donc de cette appellation
touraine chevanceaux c'est également que
le chaque cuve et chaque millésime doit
être validé il n'est pas rare que les
domaines accueille plusieurs cars de
touristes par jour
la rançon d'un succès que stéphane tient
à préserver
mais extrêmement vigilant effectivement
ne pas rentrer dans de l'accueil de
masse on ne se refuse de rentrer dans
cette logique guerrière d'accueil de
masse parce qu'on veut rester à taille
humaine il faut absolument que le
concept mis en place reste sur ses
valeurs de taille ouvert l'an dernier
le domaine a remporté le top tourisme en
val de loire devant les grands monuments
de la région
je pense qu'on vit dans un monde
d'aujourd'hui qui de plus en plus
technologique de plus en plus presque
virtuel et je pense que c'est essentiel
de revenir à nos racines de revenir au
terroir de revenir
notre histoire et ce type de portes
ouvertes comme dans d'autres domaines et
bien il recrée des liens entre les
hommes et entre les territoires
[Musique]
pour la dernière étape de notre périple
nous rejoignons les bords de loire à
sancerre sonia rimbaud exploite des
vignes avec son mari et son fils sur le
coteau de sury en vaux le domaine reçoit
des visiteurs de plus en plus exigeants
il ya vraiment beaucoup d'amateurs dans
le vin que ce soit des français mais
dans non dentier et du coup quand il
arrive à la cab ils veulent connaître le
vin mais ils veulent connaître le
vigneron ils veulent connaître les
vignes le terroir et du coup il nous
pose tellement de questions que c'est
devenu de plus en plus pointues bien sûr
il ya des gens qui ne connaissent pas du
tout donc là on n'a pas le même langage
on reste abordable au niveau mais il ya
des gens qui sont très pointus qui nous
posent des questions mais vraiment
qu'ils connaissent bien leur dossier à
les passionnés du vin il y en a
énormément beaucoup plus que j'aurais pu
imaginer au départ six ans air cuvée
vendanges sonia accueille plusieurs
couples de la région pour une
dégustation
moi je connais peut-être quinze
vignerons je ne retrouve pas le même vin
à chaque et c'est c'est vraiment
agréable de faire sa ferme bio
mais la soirée n'est pas fini au pied du
coteau de sancerre un autre voyage va
commencer sonia et son fils lucien
partage avec les touristes leur passion
de la montgolfière
[Musique]
on sent tout petit petit petit ça va
ouvrir ses tout petits c'est un volume
impressionnant
ne restez pas en auto du tout au
contraire on n'a pas fait un passionnant
ce départ
[Musique]
m
goûter au privilège de contempler la
nature du ciel il faut être patient mais
ça fait bientôt à nantes était programmé
un mais la météo
ils sont jeunes belles listes d'attentes
en plus il ya un week end quatre fois on
a un rappel pour des réservations aussi
[Musique]
on en rêvait de voler c'est fait
maintenant mais je crois que avec les i
c'est vraiment super à présent et on en
fait religieux en d1
beaucoup de gens
[Musique]
les dans les années soixante dix en
californie le tourisme est devenu une
véritable plus value économique pour les
viticulteurs et culturelles pour les
vacanciers
sans doute parce que le vin est
aujourd'hui considérée comme une
authentique expression du terroir
[Musique]